Well,
I wouldn't call it open.
I close friends,
you know,
we,
uh,
she's been really helpful to me and uh,
I have so much respect for her.
Uh,
I've had the opportunity to spend time
with her a few times and I think she's
one of the most amazing individuals in
the world.
Truly.
Um,
she's done so much good for the world
and she's been so successful and she
represents herself and,
and frankly she represents black people
really well,
you know,
she,
uh,
she's someone that we are really proud
of and I'm proud to be associated with
our.
I'm proud that she loved my music enough
to recommend it to my,
to her fans and uh,
it means something.
And I think she's a great example of
someone who has been very careful with
our brand and
has a name that actually means something
that when she associates herself with
something,
it carries weight.
And how many people can say that it's
really impressive.
And,
uh,
I'm proud that she's a decided that my
music is something that she really loves
her and that she finds worth
recommending.
He has influence on global culture.
I go to South Africa and Oprah there,
I go to Europe and people have seen me
on oprah.
There.
I go to my good friend.
His mother is from Pakistan.
A CC's me on TV.
They're uh,
you know,
through Oprah and uh,
she's influential everywhere,
but clearly she has influence here in
the states.
Uh,
I mean,
I don't need to state the obvious,
but her book club obviously makes a huge
difference.
A specific artists when they go on and
perform their,
they,
their record sales go up,
mine go up when I go on their show,
uh,
it means something to be one of her
favorite things or something that she
wants to promote to the people.
It really does make a difference.
And that comes from her being known for
good taste,
known for integrity and known for being
cautious about how
you would think actually because of so
many,
uh,
different
forms of media.
So many,
uh,
disparate ways that people get
information nowadays that the influence
of one person would actually be kind of
diffused in a certain way.
But for some reason a oprah has
maintained that power.
Even as people are watching less TV and
uh,
you know,
paying attention to the Internet more,
even as people are getting their
entertainment and all kinds of ways,
they still listen to what says and a
part of it may have to do with her
audience and maybe they're,
her audience is still kind of a majority
women that stay home during the day.
And so for them,
uh,
you know,
the TV's on and Oprah's on,
she's gonna have some influence on them
and why not?
I think she uses her influence for good.